- No offense Jamie, you look very nice,
but you might have my favorite outfit on
that anyone's wore on this show.
- Okay.
- This is so cute!
- Thank you.
- It's like,
- Thank you so much.
- It's like the, like a
reinvention of Rhythm Nation,
Janet Jackson, I'm so into it.
- Oh, we love Janet.
We thought this would be perfect.
- Oh my God, it's so
awesome! I love your outfit,
I'm gonna be talking
about it for a minute.
Meet Jamie, have y'all ever met?
- Yes, no, no,
it's the first time.
- No, no, big fan.
- Nice to meet you.
- All right, we're just
bringing people together here.
- Yeah, we love it.
- Well, do you like dolce?
Have you ever had dolce? This is yours.
- I've never had.
- She, look at her.
- I just! I'm good.
Like I'm from Brooklyn.
- I'm good, she said,
- I'm a very honest person,
so if I don't like it,
I'm gonna let you know.
- It's good, it's good.
- Alright, I'm gonna see.
- And look, I like all food.
Like it's good.
- My friends know I'm so picky
my whole family.
- Oh, really? I'm, see
I really like everything
but Brussels sprouts, yeah.
- [Jamie] She likes it.
- It's good (bleep).
(all laughing)
She is like, tastes just like honey.
- Thank you so much.
- Oh my God.
Wait, we didn't want
Dominique to feel like
Brooklyn wasn't represented as well.
So, could we bring out
some Brooklyn style pizza?
(all clapping and cheering)
- Yeah!
- We like Brooklyn style pizza.
- I mean,
- Check this out.
- I can't vouch for it
because we are in Los Angeles.
- Dang, okay.
I'm just saying, like, I'm
just gonna take a bite.
- Do I just dig in?
- Yeah.
I'm gonna, look I'm a good host.
Watch, you want this one?
You were going for it,
so I'm gonna let you have it.
- I was gonna go for it.
- Okay.
- Oh my goodness.
- Look at that.
Wait, I'm gonna give you this one
cause you're a man.
- That is big.
- There we go.
- I want chili, chili flakes.
- Oh my God, I like usually the Parmesan,
they weren't thinking of me.
Oh no, it's there, okay.
I'm gonna try it.
- [Jamie] Really.
- This is good, actually.
- It just kind of feels cold
cause it's been waiting for a minute
for you to get out here.
- But you know that pizza
is good when it's cold
and it's still good.
- Still good.
- It is.
- Yeah, so.
- It's the night you drink,
you order pizza you shouldn't have,
but then you wake up the next morning
and you're like, it's still good.
- It's still good.
Leftover pizza, yeah.
- Yes, this is a real thing.
So wait, your new show is called
"Last Days of Ptolemy Grey"
- Yes.
- Ptolemy Grey,
so Ptolemy Grey, that's Samuel
Jackson's character, right?
- Yes.
- Okay,
so tell everybody what it's about,
cause that was a really fun clip.
- Oh thank you, thank you.
- Yes.
- So it's about, it's based
on a book by Walter Mosley
of the same title,
and it's about a 90 something year old man
who is suffering from dementia,
and is family kind of forgotten about him.
And my character, Robin, she's a orphan,
and she doesn't really have family.
And so she comes,
yeah they connect and they
find unconditional love
with each other, and they
kinda take care of each other.
- I love at this point in the clip though,
it was fun to me because
it's like you're almost doing
like the, does this spark joy thing.
Like you're showing him all this stuff,
it's a hoarder.
- Yes, yes.
- It's amazing, we all could do that.
How poetic is it to hear
Samuel Jackson curse?
Cause how he says (bleep) is amazing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's probably like more of haikus, like.
I don't know.
- Haikus?
(Kelly laughs)
- Like this ain't your set (bleep).
Like you know, five syllables,
and then seven syllables
and then five syllables.
- Yeah, yeah, I love it.
- But he definitely says (bleep) a lot.
- It's an art form.
I actually feel like he owns the word.
- It's his word.
- At this point it is his word.
- We're like borrowing it.
- Yeah, we're borrowing the word.
- Yes.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- How he says it is so amazing though,
you're not offended,
you're just like, yeah!
- I mean he really does say it.
- It's weird.
- It's not even that,
it's not like a act or anything.
- No, he has us like cheering for it.
- That's sweet.
- Is it like so cool to work with him too?
- Yeah, we were doing like
press junkets yesterday
and we in separate rooms in a hotel,
and then all of a sudden Sam
comes in into my interview
and just like sits behind
me, just sits there,
so I'm kinda like,
oh Sam, how you feel about this?
Look at that.
- I love this, look at him, look at that.
That's awesome.
- Yeah.
- Do you find any differences
in like Irish cursing
and American cursing?
Do you have like cooler words
that maybe we don't know?
- I don't know if cooler words,
I mean, we do it a lot,
like I do it too much and I realize.
- Me too, I blame it on being a waitress.
- Oh, I love cursing.
- Right, right, right.
I just blame it on being Irish.
- I blame it on being
Brook, from Brooklyn.
- Yeah, there we go,
everyone's got an excuse.
- Maybe I'm just not classy,
I don't know, but yeah.
- But do your kids do it?
Like our two year old,
of course she just turned three last week,
she started to like.
- Oh!
- Yeah.
- Like, she worked out
that it's a naughty word
and just like says it.
- Oh, and now it's the red button.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, welcome to my
five year old boy, yeah.
He saw Ghostbusters: Afterlife,
and apparently there's this thing,
he was like, we came, we
saw, where we conquered,
we kicked its ass.
And I was like, what?
I was like, and I was like, oh no.
I was like, you're confused,
you don't pay any bills here.
(all laughing)
I was like, you can't say
that until you pay bills.
You haven't earned it.
You're five, what are your issues?
Like, like, yeah.
Like so you have to earn it, I feel like,
but yeah, they'll say stuff.
- Is that a moon?
- It is.
- What does that mean to you?
- Well, I'm, this is funny,
my mom was like so against
tattoos my whole life,
and I have like 17 to 20, I lost count.
And she was like one day
randomly wanted to get a
tattoo with me and my sister,
and so she is the sun and
I'm the moon inside the sun
and my sister is the star.
So we all it's like my
mom, we're real classy.
- I just got a new one.
- That's nice.
- Oh, you did.
- Yeah, it called be, it
says, "be yourself love."
But it's in my mom's handwriting.
- Oh, I love that.
- So I was like moving from Brooklyn,
from East New York and coming here.
- [Kelly] I love that!
- And I always want to be myself.
That's what I actually,
what I kind of learned
on set with Sam too.
Anywhere he is he's gonna be himself.
- Yep.
- And so for me it was like,
- [Kelly] There's only
one of you, why not?
- Why not?
- Yeah.